in the United States there are a few
moments when party politics melt away
and a real issue is laid bare which is
why the debate around the TPP although
boring is riveting the trans-pacific
partnership the historic trade pact
being negotiated now by the Obama
administration TPP is good for American
businesses and American workers remember
the TPP is that secretive free trade
agreement that involves the Pacific Rim
countries which may end up looking more
like the film Pacific Rim when it comes
to the middle class and Obama was so
hoping to get Congress to give him
authority to fast-track the TPP without
letting them read the trade deal first
fast-track by the way is the legislative
equivalent of someone in an alleyway
trying to sell you an iPad it works
great man I just can't unwrap it right
now three hundred up front but guess
what it didn't pass the Senate sent a
strong message to the president today
the Senate voted 52 245 short of the 60
votes needed and the craziest part it
was the Democrats in the Senate then
voted Nate a trade agreement that
threatens the middle class we are in a
race to the bottom the losers are those
who lose their jobs oh look at the dams
they're all grown up and finding a
spinal cord of their own either way the
president still does have support from a
totally unsuspecting group who was
outraged that the bill didn't pass the
Republicans but this is one area where
the president the United States is
absolutely correct this is sort of
typical obstructionism and to have our
colleagues vote against cloture on a
bill that their president wants
more than any other bill after talk to
all of them just stop step this is crazy
though Obama hasn't gotten this much
support from Republicans since ever it
is kind of embarrassing it's like your
high school bully being the only one to
like your facebook post about dr. oz the
president must be bummed he was pushing
so hard for this bill he even tried to
promote the TPP from Oregon at the
headquarters of Nike which is like
launching a firearms buyback program
from George Zimmerman's front lawn not a
good look Obama basically picked the one
company whose brand name is
interchangeable with the words overseas
child labor crap I scuffed up my
overseas child Labor's the cute though
huh clearly the Democrats just
misunderstand what the TPP is all about
China jobs China will write the rules
out in that region workers China
business opportunities regional threats
okay yes it's true millions of jobs have
been lost to China but not without the
total and complete support of the United
States why all the backlash you can't
throw a rager at your house and then
complain about the free drinks and the
randos making out in the corner you
invited them in the end the Democrats
and Republicans may very well agree and
pass the TPP even though it'll be the
final nail in the coffin of a middle
class but until then this is some good
the trans-pacific partnership is the
largest trade deal in US history
covering forty percent of the global
economy it'll increase exports between